on va parler de ces maire écologiste qui
décident de bannir le foie gras des
réceptions officielles le maire de lyon
a annoncé cette décision hier et on va
aller à strasbourg où la décision date
de plusieurs mois mais elle passe mal
notamment auprès des professionnels du
secteur quand un calme et s'est rendu
dans la ville on garde son reportage
la mobilisation est générale ce lundi
matin au marché de strasbourg autour de
la table jean l'agriculture chambre des
métiers ou encore chambre du commerce
ces professionnels sont venus soutenir
la filière foie gras alsacienne j'espère
vraiment que la sortie de madame la
maire il ya deux trois semaines ne soit
pas contre-productive depuis dix jours
l'information est devenue publique la
maire de strasbourg ne sert plus de foie
gras aux réceptions officielles depuis
son élection une décision symbolique que
ces acteurs économiques t nonce en
appelant j'aime bars et gyan à revenir
en arrière c'est une décision qui a été
prise en cachette déjà depuis presque un
an sans que personne le sache et si
c'est ça la ville de strasbourg
aujourd'hui si c'est la façon de gérer
moi je trouve que ça devient très très
très inquiétant mais ce matin là la
préfète de région est venu soutenir les
éleveurs contre la décision de la mer
donc le ski en semi conserves canard et
tout ce qui en somme il conserva en
alsace une dizaine de producteurs
fabrique du foie gras une filière de
qualité qu'il faut défendre selon ces
producteurs qui préfèrent minimiser la
décision de jeanne marc séguin enfin
attention au signal politique
général pour la ville de strasbourg je
pense pas qu'il faille s'enfermer dans
un signal qui dirait que la ville de
strasbourg a interdit le foie gras mais
qu'on a bien une personne en
l'occurrence notre mère qui n'en mange
pas et il faut vraiment faire la part
des choses cette annonce tombe aussi au
mauvais moment pour les professionnels
la ville est connue pour ses marchés de
noël et sa gastronomie dans le foie gras
on a les foies gras entier que ce soit
en canard ou en noix l'alsace on n'est
plus dans loi donc ça c'est un seul loeb
d'un seul foie gras une unicité de goût
de textures de couleurs le foie gras
d'oie une magnifique rémanence une très
grande finesse et c'est véritablement
une texture fondante en bouche qui se
déguste tout seul sans fin sans
compatissant olivier klein est l'un des
défenseurs de la cuisine alsacienne on
peut pas toucher au symbole de l'alsace
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas avoir des
positions qui peuvent fragiliser
finalement ce qui touche à nos plus
profondes richesse à notre histoire et à
notre tradition la tradition c'est ce
qui a toujours existé ce qui existe et
ce qui existera toujours face à cette
polémique qui enfle la mairie répond et
se félicite d'avoir pu relancer un débat
sur le foie gras on peut les appeler
symbolique ces décisions mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est le débat quelle
qu'elles suscitent savoir que des
alsaciens ont dans leur grande majorité
mange de foie gras hongrois ou polonais
et sert à quoi et donc ça ça interroge
sur les impacts
écologiques environnementaux climatiques
énergétique de cette filière de
production du foie gras et puis le
deuxième sujet c'est quand même le
bien-être animal
strasbourg une de ses grandes villes
marquées en 2020 par une victoire des
écologistes avec bordeaux ou encore lyon
la mairie a déjà annoncé vouloir réduire
ainsi la place de la voiture en centre
ville c'est une mairie qui met en
application les engagements de son
programme électoral très franchement
on savait déjà en lisant le programme à
l'époque ce qui allait se passer on peut
pas reprocher à madame le maire de
strasbourg ne pas mettre en oeuvre son
programme les choses sont en train de
changer je n'ai pas le sentiment que ça
change en mieux c'est ça mon problème
encore une fois
l'écologie c'est bien mais unique au
logis à mon sens qui devrait quand même
respecter un tout petit peu les
desiderata des uns et des autres
temer écologistes solidaire dans leur
décision après strasbourg c'est grenoble
et maintenant lyon qui ont déjà annoncé
interdire le foie gras dans la réception
officielle à l'action il va ce reportage
on voit la décision là elle a été prise
il ya plusieurs mois on l'a vu elle a
été rendue publique il ya quelques jours
ce que dénoncent certains et
strasbourgeois dans ce reportage c'est
une décision qui se faire un moment
opportun et qui est opportune dans une
ville comme strasbourg on le voit là on
touche aux symboles de la triche et
simple des sénateurs reichardt a raison
a d'abord c'est une décision qui était
plaisir longtemps ils ont été élus on le
rappelle au printemps dernier un don qui
c'est en toute connaissance de cause je
dirais d'une certaine façon qu'on soit
pour ou contre est ce que dit le
sénateur et shark qui est qui connaît
bien sa ville et qui connaît bien la vie
politique française
voilà
on est on continue il y en a qui voulait
interdire le tour de france à lyon et au
naturel de france d'autres qui veulent
interdire à bordeaux
l'unification
les sapins de noël elle sauvée mais vous
voyez que même la préfète on va dans le
reportage de content mais oui mais
on sait que ce sont des gens qui sont au
sol ils sont lieven en fait ils veulent
imposer une contre culture c'est ça
qu'il faut dire c'est une contre culture
qui veulent imposer et cette
contre-culture
il n'avance pas masqué je dirai tout ça
ils veulent qu'on revienne pour certains
d'entre eux eh bien je dirais à la lampe
à huile et
une certaine forme de 10 un peu
médiévale sans doute amish d'ailleurs
oui le président de la république avait
tout à fait raison en disant ça et voilà
les dégâts que ça fait alors le problème
si vous voulez c'est que ça heurte et ça
cogne des traditions alors en alsace
c'est comme si on était on interdisait
le foie gras sainte et à rire de canard
dans le sud-ouest sa porte des
traditions c'est alors que des savoir
faire ça heurte des économies mais des
pans entiers
économique se heurte aussi l'image de la
france à l'étranger donc c'est assez
grave et tout ça bah il faut pas le
prendre à la légère je pense pas et
quand il ya des votes comme des votes
d'élections intermédiaires qui sont
souvent considérés comme des autres
mineurs voilà ce que ça donne sauf que
les
contrats
déjà il ya deux débats c'est à dire que
moi par exemple je suis pour le retour
de la clause de compétence générale pour
les collectivités souvent quand j'y sens
dit oui mais quand il y avait la clause
générale de compétence les aigus faisait
des bêtises mais la décentralisation
l'objectif c'est pas d'avoir les
meilleurs efficace et des politiques
publiques sinon il faut déconcentrer
l'objectif la décentralisation s'est
démocratisé et donc c'est le droit pour
certains élus locaux parce qu'ils s'y
sont engagés de faire des sottises quand
bien même on considère que c'est des
sottises et bien c'est une sottise
démocratiquement choisi ça c'est le
premier débat ensuite je suis premier a
moqué des affaires de sapins de tour de
france etc et c'est que parfois il ya un
côté un peu lunaire chez les mères
écologiste l'a 20 mois je suis un grand
consommateur de foie gras si vous voulez
donc absolument
avec le fois gras mais je peux également
entendre ma compagne est végétarienne je
peux également entendre l' inverse si
vous voulez sinon ce serait compliqué à
la maison donc dès le moment où vous
avez des valeurs et que vous êtes élu
sur ces valeurs il n'est pas non plus
illégitime de vouloir les marques et là
en l'occurrence on parle pas d'une
interdiction pour tous les
strasbourgeois de manger du foie gras on
parle d'une collectivité territoriale
qui dans le cas de ces réceptions des
cibles d'affirmer sa tombe de valeur et
donc de ne pas mettre de foie gras en
soit c'est quand même pas si choquant et
parce que la question du bien-être
animal elle prône aussi de plus en plus
de place dans la campagne politique
aujourd'hui oui très clairement c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement sensibles
c'est à dire que pour le coup vous avez
aujourd'hui il c'est heureux une forme
d'empathie
vis-à-vis de la cause animale d'une
grande partie de la population on l'a vu
notamment lors des résultats aux
européennes où un petit chien sur une
affiche fait plus que certains partis
qui sont centenaires donc c'est vrai que
pour un parti politique c'est toujours
porteur de s'appuyer là dessus après on
peut reprocher beaucoup de choses à
europe écologie les verts sur ce sujet
ils ont quand même été cohérent depuis
quelques années mario rafraîchir la
mémoire puisqu'on parlait du tour de
france des sapins marion effectivement
c'est pas la première fois que des
décisions prises par des écologistes
font rire oui et comme noël approche
vous propose de revenir sur cette
décision prise à dernière par le maire
de bordeaux pierre hurmic avec donc
décidé de se passer de sapins de noël je
le cite à l'époque nous ne mettrons pas
d'arbres morts sur la place de la ville
cette prise de position lui avait valu
critique menace les politiques eux-mêmes
sont en été mais les accusant le maire
de bordeaux de piétiner les traditions
voici notamment ce qu avait twitté
marlène schiappa la ministre en charge
de la citoyenneté en fait les maires
élevé c'est tout ce qui amène un peu de
joie ou de fait qui l'interdît ils sont
pires qu'idéologue ils sont rabat joie
rabat-joie pas tant que ça puisque si le
maire de bordeaux campe toujours sur ses
positions il n'y aura toujours pas de
sapin naturel sur la place devant la
mairie cette année il a néanmoins choisi
d'investir dans un sapin de verre et
d'acier couleur émeraude réalisés à
partir de matériaux recyclés et
recyclables et qui a vocation à être
utilisés chaque année autre décision qui
avait fait réagir la mère depuis lors
d'un conseil municipal en avril la mer
les aux normes ont conduit avait
expliqué son choix de diminuer les
subventions de 2 club d'aviation
précisant qu'à ses yeux la et rien ne
devait plus faire partie des rêves
d'enfants au motif qu'il n'est pas
conciliable avec un programme écologiste
soucieux de l'environnement si la mère
avait ensuite évoqué maladresse dans le
choix des mots il n'empêche qu'elle
avait là aussi été la cible de critiques
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france avait dénoncé le
totalitarisme des verts les accusant de
vouloir justement privé à les rêves
d'enfants ayant terminé avec le maire de
lyon alors qu'elle lui aussi pris la
décision d'interdire le foie gras des
rêves dans les réceptions officielles de
savines c'est à dire mais il a déjà pris
d'autres positions si on fait fortement
réagir la première date de septembre
2020 à l'époque le tour de france fait
étape à lyon et le maire grégory douce
et en privant profite pour critiquer cet
événement qu'ils jugent machiste et
polluant combien de véhicules circulent
pendant le tour est ce que les sponsors
sont vertueux combien de déchets sont
générés s'interroge-t-il et puis l'autre
polémique remonte au mois de février
2021 grégory doucet décide d'appliquer
dans les cantines des menus sans viande
mais avec neuf et poissons et ce afin de
pouvoir proposer un menu unique pour
fluidifier le service et faciliter les
règles de distanciation sociale une
décision qu'il a aussi fait réagir je
cite le ministre de l'agriculture julien
normandie arrêtons de mettre de
l'idéologie j dans l'assiette de nos
enfants donnons-leur simplement ce dont
ils ont besoin pour grandir la viande en
fait partie sauf que ce qu'on ne le dit
pas ou qu'on oublie de dire c'est que
cette décision avait déjà été appliqué
l'année précédente par un certain gérard
collomb à l'époque cela n'avait pas ému
la majorité et susciter de tels débats
gérard collomb n'avait pas été accusé
d'être un khmer vert comme leçon de
nombreux maires écologistes et sur cette
stigmatisation des écologistes voici ce
que confie yannick jadot à nos confrères
de france info en avril dernier ça
montre que l'écologie politique est une
menace pour le gouvernement cette
obsession des écologistes c'est
l'hommage du vice à la vertu est ce que
l'écologie politique c'est une menace
pour le gouvernement comme le dit
yannick jadot ou est-ce que les mains
écologistes sont une menace pour la
campagne de yannick jadot est ce qu ils
font du tort moi je pense qu'il lui faut
du temps oui je pense que bon d'abord il
ya déjà donna n'a pas réussi si vous
voulez son nom son entrée en campagne je
pense que ça patine beaucoup
probablement qu'il est trop
social démocrate compatible si vous
voulez et pas assez justement indique al
danser dans ses choix écologique on sait
que dans la famille écologique il fait
pas il fait pas vraiment là l'unanimité
est ce que les écologistes après tout la
présidentielle c'est une élection pour
eux je ne crois pas moi je pense que les
écologistes sont contre justement cette
élection le principe de cette élection
d'avoir un homme fort c'est après tout
c'est un système très bonapartiste notre
système présidentiel et ce système là ça
va à l'encontre de tout ce que les
écologistes soit justement les
écologistes c'est la démocratie
participative
horizontal et là c'est tout le contraire
donc c'est pas étonnant que l'écologie
n'arrive jamais à faire un score à la
présidentielle
oui on a un parti qui est assez peu
adapté en effet au système bona partie
de la cinquième république c'est
clairement celui qui probablement le
moins adapté dans sa génétique après les
et les écologistes y compris les mères
parlent à leurs électeurs c'est à dire
qu'il faut pas penser que pour le coup
ils sont en opposition frontale avec les
gens qui les ont élus et là dessus on
reproche également beaucoup anne hidalgo
sa politique à paris souvent quand on
vit en banlieue c'est en effet parfois
difficile de la comprendre mais elle
parle à ses électeurs elle est plutôt
populaire parmi ses électeurs idem pour
le maire de lyon idem pour le maire de
bordeaux donc là encore une fois c'est
un peu le biais de la décentralisation
quand vous êtes élu vous parlez à vos
électeurs vous faites la politique
voulue par vos électeurs
évidemment si elle semble éventuellement
bizarroïde au reste de la france et bien
c'est le problème peut-être de la
direction nationale qui voudrait
conquérir d'autres électorats mais vous
vous avez été élu pour faire le bien des
bordelais selon la vision que les
bordelais qui vous ont élus ont de leur
propre bien
[Musique]